[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing you think that
you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I be that you be
fine without
[Music]
it hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I am Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists welcome to episode
number 71 today we're going to talk
about media that can really mean social
media that can mean the news media we've
got some questions we're going to answer
today but Ryan first I I have to tell
you this one could be a total
disaster I that's how I feel every
podcast thank you for keeping that in
internalizing it you're
welcome I feel about my life every
day that's good man suppress those
emotions yes no but I I I want to
apologize in advance I overprepared for
this one and we know how I have at least
six pages of notes here and um I was up
at 3:00 a.m. this morning which is
redundant 3: this morning or 3:00 a.m.
and uh I was watching videos about this
I I was the the irony watching videos
about media yeah yeah about how to like
watch fewer
[Laughter]
videos but no I mean really this is a
topic that is near and dear to my heart
because it is you we talk about once we
get rid of the the sort of vapid
problems of consumerism in our lives and
you've become a
minimalist you you you never get there
right it's always a journey toward
living more intentionally right and and
for me like okay I no longer have a
shopping addiction or or habit but but
there are other habits that come into
place and and especially with the way
technology is changing now and and and
the way information reaches us it
reaches us in a way that is different
from any other period of time if you
look at at some um psychologists they'll
tell you well yes every generation has
been faced with these types of with
distractions right this is nothing new
the Facebooks and the Instagram and and
uh CNN.com or whatever like this isn't
new because we've always had
distractions you go back to the stoics
and they were like well your books are a
distraction they keep you from living a
real life and and and so they encourage
people often to get rid of their books
and and that's not what we do and we're
not NE neily encouraging anyone to like
jump off of social media or get rid of
your computer you know we're not we're
not trying to be Lites here but the
difference is and and I was really
intrigued by this um here's some more
irony for you so beex and I were out
eating this weekend we went to uh James
Bar and there was a glowing screen on
behind her head and eventually I just
had to switch her seats because I I I am
like a three-year-old Ella does the same
thing she sees the glowing screen and
she just stares up at the glowing screen
can't focus on the people in front of
you it's so and and that's a perfect
metaphor right because that's what what
I will do in fact there was a study that
that I read throughout the whole process
of these many pages of of notes uh that
if you put two people in a room and you
just put an am well like your phone
right there even though it's an ambient
phone it's turned off right the the
level of connection and engagement
between the two individuals in the room
goes down something something like
12% and wow even if it's a dead phone
meaning it's never worked like it's just
one of those burner phones or a demo
phone there's just something
psychological that takes your attention
away exactly and then especially when
it's on but anyway what was on on that
glowing screen behind Becca's head was
um and Beck's just kept looking at me
like like what are you looking at and
I'm like all right turn around look at
this because it was she knew we were
going to record this podcast about media
and her and I have been talking a lot
about this lately and removing those
those distractions you just put your
phone in your pocket for the listeners
here so that that is I'm going to give
us 12% more
attention well and then it's decreased
by 24% because you and I have glowing
screens in front of both of us still
with all of our our show notes on it so
Beck turned around saw the screen she
saw the Screen Man and it was uh first
off did you know Anderson Cooper is on
60 Minutes now really yeah I'm so out of
touch with like regular cable television
PR that's not even cable he's 60 Minutes
is CBS yeah yeah I'm just I'm just
thinking prime time no I think bunny I
don't think you can get Channels with
bun you have like a special digital
antenna or something don't you I was
thinking of the bunny ears that Mariah
makes you wear
sometimes Josh that's
personal so anyway uh Anders Anderson
Cooper's on 60 Minutes now and the thing
they were doing it's it was called brain
hacking was the we'll put a link to this
in the show note Sean I sent it over to
you this morning
um but uh there was no sound on the TV
so I'm trying to figure out like but you
could tell they're talking about being
addicted to screens and Anderson
Cooper's given his own sort of Spiel but
they're interviewing experts
psychologists and people in the tech
industry in particular and where I'm
taking the story here is the difference
between the the distractions of today
versus the distractions of yester year
that the biggest difference is that
there at at these big companies the New
Media new tech companies they're paying
thousands of Engineers to try to
aggregate your attention that has never
been done before in in in a way like
this so a good example of this is so you
got thousand of Engineers on Twitter
like basically saying hey how can we
make Twitter more engaging how can we
how can we draw more eyeballs how can we
keep someone's attention longer so
that's why like when you scroll now the
videos will automatically start playing
or yeah yeah literally questions are
asking are questions like how can we ra
incrementally raise someone's cortisol
level so they need to come back to this
to get a hit of dopamine and Wow
Instagram does things now and this is
incredibly pernicious uh but they they
have algorithms that will hold off on
your likes so save a bunch of you post a
picture on Instagram right and they have
and they're doing these tests like these
experiments now with in users you might
be enduser of
733 for trial study
269 and they're going to send you a
particular algorithm to see how you you
you behave so here's an example if you
post a picture and then a bunch of
people like it um I 100 people like it
okay they might save that's the magic
number for happiness by the way 100 100
likes but the problem with that is it
always changes right once you get once
all of your pictures start getting 100
likes then you want a thousand likes I
remember I posted one picture one time
and it got 8,000 likes and I'm like oh
my gosh what if we could get to 10,000
that was my first thought I'm like
that's funny hey Josh it doesn't matter
man it it it's it's irrelevant what
they'll do is you'll post that and you
gets 100 likes they'll display only 60
right away and then they'll give you 30
in a quick burst and especially people
have these notifications turned on um
and and they know that if they give you
a certain threshold of likes all at once
you're more
likely to go back to the app and engage
uh the the more pernicious example was
Snapchat now I've never used Snapchat I
know you've used it occasionally in the
past um well now you can get you can do
the same thing now with like insta
Instagram insta stories right yeah
Facebook I think is doing it now yeah
yeah yeah so anyway the with Snapchat
one thing they'll do it's the most
addictive and most used app for teens
and by the way teens are are more
susceptible to
addiction uh because of the anxiety of
of hitting puberty and and just that
that post pubescent period and remember
how anxious I was in high school I'm
still anxious now but like it's just an
anxious time you you're you're vying for
attention you're vying for acceptance
right yeah in high school and so these
devices just amp up the volume on that
anyway what Snapchat does is they they
have this uh I guess when you can send
snap apps back and forth to individuals
on Snapchat well they have the streak
like you've talked Josh you've talked to
Ryan 17 days in a row and you and what
happens is they these people want to
keep their street going they've they've
gamified the word is gamification
they've turned it into wow you feel now
compelled it's day 18 I don't have
anything to send to Ryan but now I have
to in fact some team when they go on
vacation and they can't have their
phones with them they'll give their name
username and password to their friends
so their friends can keep that streak
going because they don't want to lose
their 37 day streak or their 119 day
streak unbelievable and so so uh what
does that street get them it doesn't get
them anything other than a uh an anxious
uh feeling if they don't if they don't
continue the streak and so it gets them
anxiety it gets them I mean anxiety is
really just a type of fear right and so
many of what's going unbelievable man I
agree I think much of what's going on
here is is in fact the the quote that I
loved this this was from that 60-minute
segment I wrote it down uh we the these
apps are or or just technology in
general is on a race to the bottom of
our brain stem so they're just trying to
reach those mamalian instincts first and
the only way to do that is to to
engineer it to
to uh uh engineer it so that you are
going after someone's fear or their
pleasure the fear of missing out the
fear of of breaking your streak the fear
of losing in some way however you define
losing losing for this person might be
oh I broke my streak now I got to start
all over right or that the the the other
side is pleasure happiness uh and and
it's not real happiness it's not lasting
contentment it's these little bursts so
during the 60-minute segment that they
uh hooked Anderson Cooper up to this
like little brain wave thing and they
were measuring his cortisol boosts as
every time he would get like a little
message notification it was just enough
that he didn't notice it in his
physiology but his brain was constantly
letting go of cortisol wow and and some
of the stats here were staggering Ryan
I'll try and go through through a few of
these before we hop into some questions
here but so um you know about the
Phantom vibrate so you you and I oh yeah
dude we used to work in Telecom for a
long time and sometimes yeah you feel
your phone vibrate yeah you reach down
there's no notification or like you feel
it vibrating you reach down and realize
that your phone's not even on you
exactly it's not even there sometimes
75% of people feel Phantom vibrations
regularly yeah you know I I was getting
that the only way I could stop that was
turning off my notifications and I do I
don't get the Phantom vibrate anymore
because I might get one or two phone
calls a day not even that on average
I'll get one phone call a day but before
it was like when especially when we had
the blackberries back in the corporate
world was constant vibrating oh yeah
constant I got 250 emails a day and that
was a lot it's a lot now it was
especially a lot for back then then and
on top of that dozens if not hundreds of
text messages you you and I were were
managing a bunch of stores you're
constantly in contact pinging people
back and forth and that vibrate was just
constant and so that I mean my cortisol
levels must have been through the roof
back then and it led to a lot of health
problems by the time I was in my early
30s and I'm still dealing with I was at
the doctor yesterday going through a uh
a hormone checkup and I've been doing
some some hormone testing recently and I
I've improved significantly from last
summer but I still have I still have a
long way to go and and so that's why
this is so near and dear to me is I want
to make sure that I'm limiting my stress
levels but also I I don't want to miss
out I don't want to be the old fogy who
was just like well that stuff's bad let
me get back to reading my newspaper yeah
I remember the day before computers
right that's how I live my life yeah you
don't want to be uh uh well what's the
word what I'm looking for
a lite yes what's the other one though
not like athetic athetic that's what it
is a so an aesthetic is a person who
intends to suffer they they try to
suffer um uh maybe you were thinking of
like maybe a stoic um but yeah maybe
leite was a is a better anyway yeah I'm
with you so the original Lites they they
like tried to smash the I mean that was
the group The the Lites they tried to
smash the printing press because they
were afraid of this technology was
putting them out of business basically
so that's where the term Lite comes from
is like people who AO techn and and
think all te technological advances are
bad that is nonsense we all realize that
we're in a much better world today
because of Technology but we also need
to put some parameters around that and
and I think when we hear some of the
some of the statistics and I was trying
to get into that but I I digressed but
here's here's a few staggering
statistics for me this one isn't a stat
a stat but I I just like the term um
someone's called it the the 79th organ
the smartphone that's in our hand our
79th organ and it feels that way
sometimes I know I so when I went to the
doctor yesterday I left my phone in the
car and I did it on purpose and I do
that quite frequently on purpose but
even more so now I I'm I'm trying to be
cognizant of that but man I get that
little twinge of panic when I reach for
I just touch my pocket and it's not
there and there's that little oh
oh my goodness what what am I supposed
to do with this time mhm well I could I
could do nothing that's why I knew I
created the nothing
app but it's on your phone but that's in
your car so it doesn't really help you
there I know I was just itching from my
nothing app how can I do nothing without
my app um pull out a white piece of
paper and look that up oh that is
brilliant P
pending the nothing app now in
print
so um yeah the 79th Oregon this one was
the most depressing to me Ryan there was
a study it was in Britain so I'm
assuming you it's Western world it's
going to be fairly similar here wait let
me guess this statistic yeah every time
you check your phone a puppy dies two
puppies die oh my that is a depressing
statistic what else you got um on top of
that uh there they did a study that if
you had to choose between going without
sex or going without your phone for a
year what would you pick dude going
without my phone for a year yeah you'd
much rather go without your phone right
yes hands down 33% of people onethird
one out of three said I'd rather have my
phone than have
sex and wow I it was just I mean that
one was like almost upsetting to me
because here's why I could relate to it
I remember back in my 20s like my
marriage was failing what way before way
before I acknowledged it was failing and
I probably would have been part of that
33% so well I'm not really having sex
anyway and so I guess I'll take my phone
because I need it wow I I uh this
reminds me of a stat came out last year
maybe it was 2015 all these years run
together now but it was uh it was over
30% of people admit to like checking
their
phone like while having sex yeah yeah
well and and a Millennials so the
generation that we are either are or not
a part of we're like right on the cusp
of Gen X and and we can claim it when
it's convenient for us we can deny it
when it's convenient that's right um but
uh Millennials so people who are right
now like uh 18 to 35 mhm and they um h h
a ridiculous amount upwards of over 80%
have have at least check their phone one
time during sex at one point that is
unbelievable can you imagine Tex
messaging during sex no no or maybe
there's some kind of like thrill there
or something where it's like yeah I mean
there's a camera on your phone yeah oh
well that makes way more sense yeah but
that's
not how could I go without my phone if
I'm going to have sex I have to film
everything right uh no I mean but so so
yeah we we'll we'll dive into that let's
see if there's any more oh dude this one
is the average person right now checks
their phone 150 times per day it's a
2016 stat uh the average Millennial is
on their phone for more than five hours
a day wow and here's here's the shocking
part gen xers slightly more than that
unbelievable yeah so uh and then uh
we're also so we're checking 150 times
but we're also checking in every 15
minutes and over 50% of the time we
check it it's not because there's a
notification yeah other than there's
that that notification in our brain
we've we've wired in a habitual
notification oh my goodness every 15
minutes you could be one of those
Engineers well and we'll get to that
well actually how do you make the brain
give notifications that's how you do it
with cortisol should we talk about the
app right now or are we going to wait
for that I think we let's wait till the
first caller I think there's some good
stuff or maybe it's the second caller I
don't know but uh before before we get
into uh the app there was another app
that I wanted to talk about just because
we're talking about the gamification
well one of the engineers was who who I
saw on the 60 Minutes piece and there's
a bunch of like overtime clips that I
watched about it and uh he was tired of
tricking people into doing stuff with
his apps basically for the companies he
he worked for as a contractor and what
what he did was uh he created a new app
it it was called space okay and you've
never heard of it I'm I'm certain of
that because it does doesn't exist in
the app store because Apple refused to
carry the app in their App Store here's
why they refused to carry it's not cuz
it was a bad app so here's what it did
anytime you engage with a social media
platform so you have you have Facebook
on your phone yeah you have Twitter on
your phone whatever if you go click on
the Instagram icon okay the space app
interrupts and it says let's breathe
together for 12 seconds that's it let's
just slow down and breathe and and and
Apple's response to that was well if uh
if it limits the amount of of Engagement
with other apps on the phone we're not
we're not willing to put it in the App
Store wow and that's really unfortunate
to me man because I really like Apple's
products I think they make really great
Hardware uh they make okay software a
lot of times but um uh it's just
disappointing to see that because that's
something I would have paid for because
I think it it allows us to retrain
ourselves and regain some of that
self-control it's a great reminder like
like I there's nothing I can do for
these next 12 seconds and it's not
enough to do something else so I might
as well just breathe yeah you know we're
supposed to take six breaths a minute uh
and and we are doing something like 20
or 30 breaths a minute because we're
breathing so shallowly we're not using
the full capacity of of our lungs right
right and so when you and I were at at
yoga this weekend we went to a yoga
class and we are not the quintessential
yogis there's everyone else in the class
like their feet are behind their heads I
can tell
well he just like it must be the same
people in that class uhhuh because you
know when he was doing the I think it's
like a sun salutation or whatever SE uh
circuit that like they go in I just
remember like at a certain point I'm
like all right I'm just going to stop
faking this uhuh and I'm just going to
like stand here and like try to follow
anyway I just was not very uh not very
in sync with everyone else with the the
salutation I'm like looking at I'm like
he's like uh you know downward dog Cobra
upward dog bend over back grab your
ankles Warrior 3 and I'm like what's
Warrior
3 like I know one and two but I didn't
even know there was it is there a
warrior 4 oh my God I look over you have
a bow and
arrow what isn't
it um but man he was talking about how
we we don't breathe enough and how we we
use only 60% of our lungs or something
right right yeah because we're we're
we're sitting at these desks all day and
we're just like breathing really shallow
and and and pausing and taking those
deep breaths it it does make a
considerable difference on your stress
levels as well so CH it's it's one of
the best ways to change your state in
fact this morning like I was super tired
cuz I got up way too early I was excited
to to record this today and so I'm like
I got to do more research and and so uh
I by 8 o' this morning I was super tired
so I just went out and walked for 45
minutes like really briskly and it was
like 30 degrees outside but uh man it it
it helped wake me up because it got me
breathing again right it's the reason
people take up smoking I mean talk about
a a bad habit and really that's what
we're talking about about about today I
just want to be clear we're not
encouraging people to smoke no no no no
um but I think what you're saying is is
like when someone takes up smoking it's
because it forces them to take in those
large breaths it provides that certainty
and and at regular intervals too your
body feels much calmer when it when it
does it right can you imagine if if we
all just took smoke breaks but didn't
smoke and we just breath breaks yeah
just you you go do a breath break every
hour you're so Progressive I mean
how um I'm gonna go take my smoke Breck
I didn't know you smok I don't
yeah um but I I I I found that uh when I
breathe it totally calms me down in fact
the the another part of the research I
was doing I saw that it your your body
will relax significantly I do this when
I when I do my my daily physical therapy
I when I'm I I do a wall sit so I sit
against a wall at like a what is that a
90° then a 90° angle um my you know you
get it right yes you see wall you sit on
the wall you sit on the wall with 100
180 degrees total I got you no I know
what you're saying man Josh is sitting
against the wall like there's a like
he's sitting on a chair but there is no
chair yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
and it's a
metaphor I don't know for
what the emperor's new chair yes um
anyway um I will do that and then I take
these deep breath and if you breathe out
for at least eight seconds your body
knows that it's in no danger because
I've got this abundance this luxurious
abundance of free air like clearly I'm
not being chased by a lion and so your
body just calms down and so so that's
one of the things I do if you if you
breathe in deeply and then breathe out
for at least 8 seconds it's actually
harder than it sounds like because that
one outward continuous breath but man it
really changes your state so what other
stats you got before we uh di into the
questions let's see what else we have
here if there's
anything um these are all the stats for
now so okay let's uh uh should we just
should we dive into the questions let's
do it all right our first question is
from Michelle in San
Francisco I am wondering what you do
about about the onslaught and Deluge of
media that we have every day I've signed
off of almost all social media sites I
rarely look at the internet except to
see what's going on in the news and
usually the news can be pretty
depressing and I'm wondering about the
effect that the news diet would have on
our minimalist
Lifestyles so Ryan I know you've been
dealing with less news in your life
recently right ever since our uh
distraction
episode the the the values episode or
the values episode did we do
distractions well we were talking about
what what what distraction so there were
the imaginary values and you said for
you news was an imaginary value at least
at that time yeah and no I I deleted my
apps and dude I got to tell you it I
will go like on the browser every once
in a while uh so just to give you an
example when I had when I had like BBC
and then like uh Apple
has this news app where it just streams
everything into your phone okay um dude
I I would spend on average per day I'd
probably spend an hour maybe even longer
and I was like I was I was twitching and
I didn't even like realize how much it
was affecting me until that that podcast
that we we
recorded and um yeah those first couple
days dude it was hard because I was like
kept twitching for news and I'd go on
the browser mm but then like as soon as
I go on the browser now like I am
reminded how useless the news sites are
ah it's like I just I just realized like
oh wow like these headlines aren't that
important even like with some like
Terror attacks or like you know somebody
stealing a a truck and you know running
over I mean all these things that happen
they're not it's not important for my
life I mean my you know my feelings and
my heart certainly goes out to any
victims of many any those situations but
uh all that does is cause panic and
stress for me yeah I I remember this
like toward the end of last year U there
was a time where you were consuming a
lot of news and I think a lot of the
Western World especially especially
United States was consuming a lot of
news and you were visibly more upset and
not even visibly sometimes you would
even like voice it you I'm distraught
like guys like before we record this
podcast I got to get this out yeah yeah
and it's because of those headlines and
now uh like this morning Mariah and I
woke up I am you know downstairs like
making coffee getting ready for the
podcast and I can hear Mariah like
moaning and groaning and she's like and
she'll start reading headlines to me and
I'm like oh what is that about and then
she'll start telling me and then like if
if it gets to be too much I'm like all
right this is why like that that stress
that you're feeling right now like that
is what I'm trying to avoid
um but yeah man that the the news can
definitely clutter can clutter my mind
if I allow it to yeah I think I think
for me I I don't there's no news site to
go on to or anything like that so I'm
I'm on pretty much a news diet I where I
just a news fast really I mean I get a
lot of news from Twitter that's where
I'll get like some headlines and stuff
and so you have a a curated feed of of
of of places that you follow that are I
don't know if you're anything like me
but there it's on both sides of the
spectrum well it's usually like the
people I F like uh Colin right for
example he's always got some like cool
science news stuff that he'll retweet um
every once in a while yeah just someone
who I'm following will retweet something
that's really good or share something
but those I find are more meaningful
that stream is more meaningful for me
than having the BBC News app or than
having like that that news amp that app
that pumps all the news outlets into
your phone in a way you're letting
people you trust like Colin curate some
news for you because he may be better
equipped here's some news like is it is
it uh urgent news no but it's the most
interesting of the news and I know that
99% of the news stories that show up on
my Twitter feed are not going to stress
me out if anything it's more informative
of some type of new algorithm they're
working on for prime numbers or some
scientific discovery like it's more
applicable to our everyday life instead
of just
uh creating or disturbing you know your
the state that you're in if that makes
any sense it does so so the person we're
talking about is Colin wght and he does
a really good job with his Twitter
account in particular of tweeting out
useful things you can follow him at
Colin is my name if you're looking for a
useful place to follow he he certainly
puts out a lot of uh just really good
different types of news and that's
really what I want to say was really
interesting here Ryan you said science
news so I think it's also important for
us to delineate the different types of
news as well
right so there could be science news and
in many cases that will stress you out a
lot less than political news right
unless it was some type of like asteroid
heading for earth yeah and then you have
a right no chance of anyone surviving
well yeah then then well I
mean unless you're the Buddha or
something you're going to be pretty
stressed out about that um and and the
my point is when something that that's
asteroid in nature uh it's when it
reaches that level it's going to reach
me somehow I don't have to be subscribed
to a million different news feeds it
will find its way to me uh in fact like
with the when the the Syria thing
happened uh this past week with the
bombing uh in Syria it was um like I had
several people just send me a text
message say here's what's going on in
Syria right now I'm like oh okay like
the most important news makes its way to
me and even that one like you said
there's nothing I could really do to
take action at the time and so I asked
myself a qu couple questions with
respect to the news that I and I'll talk
to you about how I get news cuz Twitter
is is one way that that I'll I'll I'll
curate my news I don't follow a bunch of
people on Twitter but I do use it to
follow uh the places that are most
interesting to me to get the headlines
but I don't check it regularly and in
fact we'll we'll get to that a little
bit uh a little bit more on the next
question but the the other thing that I
do is I ask two questions is this useful
so is the news
useful in your life and if so that's
great because we'll often say yeah it's
useful it adds value to my life but is
it the most useful use of that time and
this is a good time to to transition
into the app you and I have been using
this past weekend we we started doing
some phone tracking uh the app is called
moment and I put it on my phone just
because I knew we were we were going to
record this episode and I was Disturbed
Ed by the amount of time because I'm
pretty good about using my phone putting
it in the car I never have it on the
table in front of me if uh beex and I
are at dinner and I need to get it out
for some reason I'll say hey would it be
okay with you if I do this real quick
here's why I want to do it not that I
need her permission but I I want to show
whoever I'm with that I care enough
about our interaction but even
considering all that and all of my
intentionality that goes into the
smartphone use I found well I found two
things disturbing so I'll pull it out
and look at my average real quick so
first off let me acknowledge this I by
putting this tracker on my phone I
immediately noticed that I wanted to
reach for the phone less because I knew
I was being I was AB I was being tracked
abut so my numbers would actually be
higher than this I am I am absolutely
certain of that so let me just talk
about this so you how many full days do
you have so far oh I I accidentally
opened the nothing app again it's right
next to my
tracker for those of you who don't know
what the nothing app is it's April
Fool's joke that we did with our good
friend mat the aella who directed our
documentary I can't believe you
downloaded the app and still have it
that's pretty funny I do still have the
app but um I every time I can delete
like a little window icon off of my
phone like it gives me so much joy Ah
that's nice
so I haven't used this I haven't used
this app in forever I'm going to go and
get rid of it that's like the dopamine
of intentionality there man that so um
let's see if I go to this so let's just
talk about what moment is I was in the
the sauna this weekend on Sunday morning
and beex and I were talking about it and
I was talking about the usage that's on
this thing and so it tracks all of your
usage but it also will track your usage
per app or yeah per app that you're
using right you have to take a
screenshot in the morning it send you a
reminder to take a screenshot at some
point in the morning so well if you do
that each morning uh you take a a
screenshot of your battery screen
basically this breaks it down by app I
have how you oh I didn't you could do
that there's a video in there it shows
you how to do it but um you won't so
there's no way to go back and like see
what I spent on Sund no you have to do
you have to have screenshot each day
okay you can do it by the week but then
it's it's less accurate obviously but uh
it's just one it's one quick screenshot
in the morning and I mean it takes 5
Seconds to do but it's very useful for
me you take a screenshot of the app like
when you pull it up no you take a
screenshot of the video yeah you take a
screenshot of you go to the settings and
click battery and it shows you what your
battery usage is for each app that you
have and it will show you what you're
using so um anyway I was in the sauna
and I was talking to this this couple
who had a few teenage kids so Ella's
three so she doesn't have a phone she's
at least one year away from having a
phone wait a minute no no I mean that
that's sadly what used to happen with us
in the corporate world there were a lot
of 5-year-olds who got sold phones when
we worked in Telecom and uh and I mean
quite often it was parents coming and
wanting that phone for their kids other
times it was us encouraging our
employees to sell phones 15 bucks a
month right and and so no obviously a
5-year-old does not need a phone I'm
sure there's yes you don't you don't
need to tweet us telling us there's the
one circumstance I get there are
exceptions to every rule sure so uh but
most 5-year-olds or three-year-olds Ella
will be four next month and she does not
need a phone but the couple I was
talking to in the sauna they were like
wait what they overheard just back I
talking wait what is this app and it's a
free app but there are like paid
upgrades and stuff so you can do whole
family tracking plans but you can turn
off off your kids phone at certain times
like if you always eat dinner between
6:00 and 7 you can have it off like so
their phone just is functionally
disabled between 500 and 6 you can do it
so that after 700 p.m. the phone is
disabled and they can't use it or it's
disabled during the day except for
emergencies I love that idea man of like
being able to uh and I think the app
even pitches it that way of like making
time uh during dinner to where like the
family has to at least put their phones
away they have no choice but to put
their phones away yeah absolutely and so
I I think that well that that actually
reminds me Ryan I was the first thing I
wrote down here is uh first thing I
wrote down on my third page of notes uh
we we were listening to this this
podcast episode that the big think
podcast episode okay and um it was with
an author his name is Adam alter and he
wrote a book called irresistible and
it's about Technology's role in our
lives today and one of the tips he gave
so if you have like the moment app
that's great but you can also just put
put some fairly um basic rules in place
keep your phone somewhere where you need
to walk to it in order to get to it
right and and that will a limit the
amount of times you can go reach for
because you have to do it with intention
MH but also it will it will force you to
think about do I actually need to do
this yeah it's like it doesn't make you
breathe but it's kind of like that app
where it's like right hey do you really
want to go look at your phone right now
do you really want to look at this up
yeah it's like it's in in fact even
asking yourself a question like that
there's a lot of great questions that
you can ask yourself you know like what
would the best version of myself do
right now would the best version of
myself pull this out and look at the
phone at the urinal I don't know I don't
think so for me personally the answer is
definitely no and and the the the
question for you is I I don't know I I
don't know what the answer is for you is
it appropriate for you to do that the
Ural does it matter that's really up to
you for me absolutely not that's not
what the best version of of myself would
do and here's the other question after
I've been looking at this tracking app
Ryan is how could I have better spent
that time yeah and and so uh I gave you
that stat earlier that Millennials spend
5 hours a day on their phone thankfully
I don't spend five hours a day so I've
had it on here since uh last Friday
we're recording this on a Tuesday and so
so Saturday Sunday you got three full
days basic basically I have Friday
Saturday Sunday Monday four days okay
okay so uh cuz I download Friday morning
gotcha gotcha so all right so what's
your average well so it it varies so
again I I think that my average drop
down significantly so beex and I spent
the whole weekend together we did all
kinds of really cool stuff and uh well
actually so Friday was I did an 1 hour
and 9 Minutes mhm and on Saturday it was
1 hour and 11 minutes Sunday was only 46
minutes and the the interesting thing
about about that was beex and I went to
the float tanks for 90 minutes so I I
certainly could have had my phone in the
float tank right then me and you and Bex
and Mariah we went to yoga that was
another roughly 90 minutes right and so
yeah that's a large chunk of my day
right there and then also in the morning
we were in the sauna for over an hour
and so that's at least four maybe even
five hours that I wouldn't have had any
access to my phone whatsoever I
shouldn't have had had any access right
uh and that doesn't include meals and
all this other stuff but I still spent
46 minutes on my phone and then the
following day Monday I spent 2 hours and
46 minutes that was yesterday 2 hours
and 46 minutes and I actually feel
better about that one than I do the
previous days and and let me talk about
why I I think that so it was beex and I
spending a weekend together and I'm I'm
looking at this I spent on Saturday I
spent an hour and 11 minutes on my
phone what could I have I what could
have I done better with that time and I
I look at these different apps and it's
like you did messages for 13 minutes you
were on the home lock screen for 12
minutes and there was a bunch of other
sort of one minute things I was on
Instagram for seven minutes um all right
then yesterday the 2 hours and 46
minutes I picked up my phone 45 times
okay mhm and on I was on Facebook for 31
minutes now that was all during I don't
ever get on Facebook I don't like
Facebook personally but that was we did
a Facebook live session for the people
who do get value from from Facebook so
that was so I do feel good about that
right like that was an intentional use
of the phone like we were broadcasting
to an audience Instagram was 23 minutes
I don't even remember looking at
Instagram yesterday but apparently I
fell down a rabbit hole for 23 minutes
wow I don't remember and then Safari was
18 minutes yesterday well that was me
going over test results with my doctor
on my phone and so I feel totally fine
with that right uh my home lock screen
17 minutes so that's probably listening
to podcasts or checking the time that
kind of thing messages 17 minutes that's
useful I was on Twitter for 17 minutes I
don't remember getting on Twitter that
is maybe it was
Ella she stole your phone she was
checking her Ellis at Ellis sandwich
account she does tweet quite a bit tell
me some things I say
[Laughter]
she does say that uh I was on YouTube
for 16 minutes um man I wish I would
have known about this screen capture
thing I thought I thought I'd upgrade it
to get the individual no no and the
individual results I was keep track that
this week and let you know where I'm at
next week I was on overcast for nine
nine minutes which is the the podcast I
was on the phone for 9 minutes which
that's cool um photos for 4 minutes that
that seems productive to me looking
through photos I mean I mean it can be
at least I was on my calendar for 2
minutes definitely needed that and so
yesterday I mean there was there was
certainly some misses here I could have
done better but I I think I needed my
phone for at least two hours yesterday
but I look at it this weekend I'm like I
I wasted time with beex so I could check
a phone at some
point and that just it just doesn't feel
good to me man is it useful yes is it
the most useful use of my time no
obviously not and I think I do a good
job I I this was going to help me do a
lot better job I think and um yeah
definitely um I've so I've got some like
just highle stats uh yesterday I was 2
hours and 46 minutes but I woke up at
like wait we had the same exact
time what did what did you have
yesterday was it 246 that's hilarious I
so how do I go back um how does this
phone I I will tell you though that it
definitely was like two hours of that
had to have been reading I wish I had
the individual tracker thing but but uh
I woke up like 3:00 in the morning mhm
and like when I wake up like I'll you
know put the the night mode on so the
blue light isn't keeping me up and I'll
sit there and read until I get sleepy
yeah but if you leave it on airplane
mode it doesn't track
it
oh H well I'm glad we're Lear I'm
learning how to use this app now and so
I think that's the point like we think
we're using the phone one way I
literally don't remember getting on
Twitter yesterday and I was there for 17
minutes that's hilarious yeah so on
average I'm at like and then I was an
hour and 42 on Sunday but see check in
the like doing the admin stuff for the
minimalist Facebook M I would dude we
need to get rid of Facebook and email by
the end of the year well let's talk
about that dude that's the most like
talk about instant stress and then it's
on my mind until I get down to zero
notifications yeah I well I I I remember
getting on Facebook last year and I
figured out how to check messages at one
point like I didn't know there's there's
like a I guess personal message on there
or whatever and I just had hundreds if
not thousands of messages and and I'm
like well I'm not even going to try to
go I mean that's that's the worst way to
contact me so uh but in in terms of
notifications there are a couple apps I
do have not I turn them off for
everything including text messages uh I
get a vibrate for phone calls uh I I get
this the this moment app the only time
they ever send a notification is to take
your screenshot in the morning so you
take your screen and and then if you
ever put your phone in airplane mode it
just lets you know uh tracking is
disabled while it's in Airplane so
that's a good hack if you put this thing
on airplane mode it's a paper weight uh
but you can still read on it right yeah
and and so uh and actually look look it
just happened right now because my phone
is on airplane mode it said uh tracking
has been paused because you're in
airplane mode and so I and then the
other the other app that I have a
notification for and this one actually
has a vibrate on it as well is the
parking app that that's here in Missoula
because cuz if oh it'll let you know
like when your time is expired yeah yeah
and so um that way I don't get any more
parking tickets so that one that one's
actually helpful out of all the people
of all the friends I have in Missoula
you've gotten the most parking tickets
for sure I'm sure I've gotten more
parking tickets here that I just forget
to pay the meters man like it's it's
never intentional yeah i' I've gotten
one and it was for that exact reason I
was like oh yeah the meter I'll just
show up like I'm like is it today
Saturday isn't it free it is somewhere
uh anyway so I alluded this earlier but
let's at least talk about it real quick
the uh think again podcast it's a big
think it's a um it's a podcast where
they interview people and and just talk
about different topics and they
interviewed Adam alter and uh he he
wrote that book irresistible and there
was there was actually let's just put a
link to this I was going to read from it
but to save time here Sean there I I
sent you a link this morning to this
wired article it's a it is a excerpt
from his book irresistible and so the in
the interview he just talks about how we
have I mean we've we we've grown so
addicted but there's two types of
addiction and for Millennia we have
had
um is it substance yeah substance
addiction so like alcohol yeah drugs I
got you drugs um and but now we have
these behavioral addictions and the one
exception is gambling gambling's been
around as an addiction for a while and
within the last few few decades the last
hundred years for sure they have
gamified the heck out of gambling so
that it is it is Uber addictive but
other than that we have not evolved to
be able to deal well with
behavioral addictions and and so this
this phone in my pocket this news that
is always coming to me on the tablet or
whatever else that that is in front of
me this is a new type of addiction
and I love the way in that podcast Ryan
he he talked about addiction he he
talked about it it's when you want
something but don't like it h and I mean
it it was like when you think about a a
heroin addict doesn't like the fact that
he is a heroin addict anymore no no no
any drug addict like like they're as
they're taking the drug and like the
placebo effect starts to kick in just
because their body knows they're about
to get that drug uhhuh like as soon as
they feel calm at least for me like
every time I'd feel calm I'm like and
man I really shouldn't be doing this
like I wish I didn't have to take this
drug to feel calm no you're absolutely
right it is it is uh you wanted it but
you didn't like it yeah exactly exactly
the only thing the only exception to
that would be like coffee I love I love
me some coffee right but I understand
what you're saying though for all
intents and purposes for this
conversation but what and you want you
you want coffee right but you also don't
want 20 cups in a day right I also don't
want the stained teeth right right but
you don't want those 20 and you would
actually you would end up not liking it
at that point as well right so it's
there is some threshold with coffee
where you're like all right like there's
diminishing returns here this is
awful but anyway he in there in in the
podcast I I'll just leave off on one
last thing here is
ultimately there aren't no one's going
to provide the solution for you the the
FDA isn't going to step in and nor do we
want them step in and regulate the the
technology whatever Government Agency St
I mean they did this for cigarettes
obviously right and and there there will
probably be some really compelling
arguments that the consequences of
Technology addiction especially for
people who are teens right now are going
to be longlasting the same way addiction
to Tobacco is uh has long-term
consequences we didn't know the
consequences of long-term tobacco use in
the 30s the 40s and the 50s that's why
you go back you look at photos or video
of people back then everyone was smoking
smoking while they're pregnant yeah yeah
my mom smoked while she was pregnant in
the
80s uh but she was born 1945 and like
she was she was used to that that that
culture right yeah that's crazy and so
um we that has been replaced with this
new drug and there are rehab centers all
over the place now especially for where
they take away their phones and and on
the 60- Minutes piece I saw that one kid
was like what do I what am I supposed to
do with my hands now they took my phone
away what I don't know what to do with
my hands wow and it's that addictive and
so uh the thing he talked about was was
self-control in this podcast the think
again podcast uh Adam wter I'm talking
about here he you know if you go to the
grocery store and they have these like
100 calorie snack packs mhm did you know
that they obviously cost way more it's
like a thing of checks mix and it's like
$8 for six packs or something right it's
an absurd amount but you can buy you
could buy that the same ingredients for
$2 or whatever what you're you're not
paying for the ingredients you're paying
because you're Outsourcing yourself
control yeah you're paying for the
portion control yes yeah and you're
letting someone else do do the control
for you so I'm going to encourage you to
listen to that podcast we'll put a link
to that in the show notes and then one
last thing for Michelle here right and
this this quote stood out to me it it
was from Dan Savage and he he was
talking about it with respect to uh
video games and then also for kids and
then porn for adults he was talking to
his his little kid about like the game
or the TV it wasn't a video game it was
him watching TV and he said hey son are
you are you having fun right now
watching that and the kids's like yeah
this is great I think I think of Ella
with this too CU she loves watching
Peppa Pig like Peppa Pig is just the
bees knees to her
man and uh uh and she she loves watching
it and and with Dan he'll say are you
having fun and kid's like yeah this is
great he goes no you're not what you're
not having fun you're watching other
people have fun yeah or you're having
fun watching other people have fun right
right I mean and and so I I think that's
the thing to keep in mind with with uh
any of any of this stuff like when we're
participating in incessant checking mhm
it mimics the the fun and the the
pleasure centers of the brain but it's
not a real it's not the real experience
of outside of the glowing screen and so
I I want anyone who's listen to this to
keep that in mind there's nothing wrong
with the tool but we need to take it
back as a tool and stop bludgeoning our
our neighbors to death you it's like a
knife yeah a knife can be used to make a
really great meal or can be used to to
kill your neighbor and we need to stop
doing that metaphorically with with our
technology and the only way for us to do
that is for us to sort of self regulate
yeah I think this is a really good uh
just the phone usage is a really good
example of like well people always ask
us well okay now that you guys are
minimalists like now what do you do like
you know and how do I get to that point
where I can look at myself and say like
well now you know I'm a minimalist and
at the end of the day I mean what do we
always say is like hey there is no end
of this journey it's just you know
constantly looking at that next Horizon
but if you think about your phone there
isn't you could put all the best habits
in place and keep that going for six
months right if you stop it after 6
months you're going to fall right back
into wherever you were you know before
you started putting in those good habits
so yeah I think that it's it's about
yeah man finding those good habits to
incorporate uh putting some restriction
on yourself having a little bit more
selfcontrol the more you do it the
easier it gets but we have to always
keep ourselves in check always with with
the these types of things because
otherwise you're going to have to go
without and that's not that's not the
solution here if you have uh a person
who's an alcoholic can go without
without alcohol without any consequences
but a person who who is addicted to
email or addicted to their computer or
whatever they generally have to use that
you know you have to have email address
to get a job these days right um or to
apply for a a Visa or work visa or I
mean there are there are so many reasons
that you need an email address so it's
it's it's not the same type of addiction
because we're forced to to be a part of
that at least to some extent and and so
it's really about pulling back the
Reigns as as you said Ryan Michelle
before before we move on to our next
question uh you're in San Francisco and
we are coming to San Francisco in fact
we're coming to 46 different I'm sorry
47 different cities on the less is now
tour so Sean if you could reach out to
Michelle and get her a couple tickets if
she's interested in going to our San
Francisco event that's uh during the
first leg of the tour 19 cities are
already announced over at Les is now.com
by the time this uh this episode airs we
will be we we have already had our first
four we're actually so we're recording
this the Tuesday before we leave to to
go to this first Little Wave of the tour
we're going to be in uh Pittsburgh
Burlington Boston and Portland Maine but
if you're hearing this it's too late
we've already been to those cities and
boy were those great events weren't they
Ryan oh man I couldn't believe what
happened in
Burlington well we promised we wouldn't
talk about it on the air at least not
yet what happens in Burlington stays in
Burlington isn't that City
motto after that we're going to uh
Spokane and Seattle and Portland Oregon
so there's still tickets available for
all of those and then also a bunch of
other cities Grand Rapids Chicago
Madison Minneapolis San Diego Los
Angeles San Francisco Indianapolis
Cincinnati Columbus and Cleveland
there's a list of 28 other cities that
we working on booking you can find all
the details and see the tour trailer as
well over at Lis
now.com all right Ryan who's next up
this next call comes all the way from
Soul South Korea let's listen to Clyde's
question if you could only choose one
social networking or one piece of social
media uh what would it be and why
Twitter Instagram which one would you
stick with I think the first question to
ask here because this is going to be a
highly individual qu answer right
because I know my answer is going to I'm
going to say Twitter but there are some
people who like I was talking to beex
about this over the weekend and she's
like I don't like Twitter at all she's
like I'm just going to delete it off my
phone like I don't really use it that
much and if I need to I'll use it on the
computer or whatever so it's going to be
different for each person and so the
question I would ask myself if I was
asking this question Clive is how do you
use social media and and what are you
going to use it for and and there are
sort of two ways I use I use it
personally and then and then from a
business perspective or what I would
just call a broadcasting perspective
right so Ryan and I will use social
media in fact we have a social Med media
manager Jessica who helps post a bunch
of different articles she also helps
with some of the engagement on there but
how do you use social media because on
the personal side I rarely use it at all
uh I mean I will occasionally post a
picture on the Instagram and that's less
and less frequent these days on Twitter
I will I will tweet a py quote every now
and then but I use it more as a news
feed for me or an news is is the wrong
word right we were just talking about
that like defining different types of
news it's science news or or Urban
Development news I mean it has less to
do with politics and more to do with the
things I'm interested in right there's
one thing I I follow called strange maps
and it just like shows different maps
that uh you know here here is the world
split up by time zone if all the
population were equal in each time zone
I mean it there are these strange maps
at I fall so I those are things I get
value from and so what do you get value
from and how you how are you using
social media are you using it to
broadcast are you using it to
communicate with other people or or are
you using it to pacify yourself like I
was yesterday and I was on Twitter I
don't remember being on Twitter and that
is a problem and and so I I'm I'm
committed to to fix it in fact um I'm
going to try an experiment Ryan I dare
you I'm pulling out my put that Bunny
and Beaker away hey that's for the next
podcast we're
recording um well why you doing what
you're doing over there man uh I would
definitely go to Instagram as mine uh
but that's because it's it's like
Twitter and in this sense I feel like
people don't really post long posts when
they do I just don't read them um I
don't post long post one or two
sentences uh I like not being confined
to the 140 characters although I like if
you look at my post I don't think I've
ever gone over 140 characters but really
for me it's uh it's like an ephemeral
way to catch up with friend like I love
seeing uh the bergamont um it's a a band
that Josh and I uh have kind of
developed a friendship with they open up
for us in Grand Rapids like during our
2014 tour but it's cool to like see what
those guys are up to it's cool to see
like colins Adventures um I like to post
very deliberately uh like pictures from
different travels that Mariah and I have
MH um but it's like uh I I hate get on
social media period but it it is one of
those things where um if I'm looking for
an ephemeral you know five minutes and I
don't feel like pulling up the Kindle
app and reading uh then I can get on
Instagram and and I think in the same
token too like I I like to support the
people that are on there like hey I know
we don't talk but I do want you to know
that I do care about what's going on in
your life and thanks for sharing what's
going on in your life um that could
probably be taken to a really crappy
level cuz meaning that there are better
ways to show people that you care about
them yeah for sure but uh but yeah uh
but I also know that some people do
equate you know the they equate like
with likes MH and and that's dud I'll
like something on Facebook and and
people go oh my God Ryan Nicodemus liked
my liked my post and you know what like
I'm really happy that I can make that
person happy yeah yeah I get it man I um
I've had actual famous people who have
tweeted us before and it's like it is
the it's like oh you know this person
you know likeed the film or whatever and
and um I understand that that you know
it sort of gives you that bit of
validation but then I have to start
questioning like you know what man I'm
I'm totally valid without that right
like how much validation do I need I
don't ever it's funny man I feel like I
like Oprah Winfrey could walk through
this door right now yeah and of course I
would be like oh my God Oprah wi but
like at the end of the day You' be like
what the hell is she doing be like what
are you doing here Oprah no um no like
at the end of the day though uh I feel
like because we've had such a slow build
with this yeah that like I would you
know treat her like any other person
it's like when we met Rob Bell although
I was like really nervous when we did
that podcast with Rob Bell really uh
yeah like so nervous well mainly because
I was just like you know I was like I
really want to do a great job for Rob I
want this to be a great robcast I want
this to be good for him and you know
when I put pressure on myself like that
is when I uh typically get nervous and
and and I'm not uh you know totally up
to part anyway it was a fine podcast but
when we were sitting there in his
kitchen and like having a juice it was
just like wow like Rob's regular dude
he's got kids and wife and it's a really
you know and that's that's how I feel
now like so I guess what I'm saying is
to your point of I don't need the
validation from a celebrity or someone
famous it certainly is nice to get to
know people but for me it's even nicer
to like get to know someone and realize
like how they are just a regular person
yeah yeah and and the cool thing is I
think sometimes social media can augment
that right yeah social media for me the
reason I say Twitter is there was a time
especially like 2010 2011
where most of the the friendships I have
forged on the online World initiated
from from Twitter at some point and we
had far fewer followers on there
although it it's the platform that I
enjoy the most and we certainly have the
the smallest audience out of that
compared to Facebook or or Instagram or
even Google+ um I could not even tell
you what any of our followers are at
right now well I I I don't know the
specific numbers but I can tell you that
it's appreciably less on Twitter because
fewer people use it right but it's still
my my personal favorite because I've
been able to connect with more people I
think it's a better communication tool
and I think the 140 characters that
brevity forces uh some forces people to
improve their writing you they say
brevity is the soulle of wit and I think
that's true you you you are forced to to
have these these limiting constraints
that make you more creative and and so
I'll use that as a writing platform for
ideas sometimes you go back look at my
tweets at jfm you'll see that pretty
much the only thing I tweet these days
are just little lines of of essays I'm
I'm working on and so if you see like a
tweet storm all of a sudden I all of a
sudden came up with six great lines and
what'll happen is most of them won't fit
into the essay or they don't work just
right and so they won't make the essay
but they at least live out there on
Twitter and someone if it Inspire
someone I think that's great but what I
don't want to do is add to the noise and
and so I'm constantly trying to turn
down the noise so the experiment I want
to get back to I'm going to do real
quick is I'm going to delete social
media apps for my phone a double dog D
you I'm doing it right now watch this I
hold it in wait that didn't work it
won't let me delete it oh my God it's a
government
conspiracy the reptile people did it
they're putting fluoride in the water oh
my God pile
[Laughter]
government all right I'm going to do
that with you let's see who lasts the
longest nice okay all right you're it
here folks done what does the winner get
their pride back Google Plus dude I
don't you know the I don't ever use
Google+ why do I even have that on my
phone Instagram see you later Instagram
see you later Twitter see you later
FaceTime wait a minute that's not a well
that's an app but it's not social media
how are you using fa time none of your
business see you later Snapchat see you
later Periscope wait a minute do they
still exist oh yeah man we did a
periscope last month here's the other
cool thing though we so so let's talk
about this real quick Ryan um we'll
still use social media for work
obviously right it makes sense to
broadcast and and if anything we want to
improve the O overall content of the
nonsense that's going out there we we
never post anything that's click baity
or or anything like that we post only
things add value to your life and and
that's really Our intention and so so
that that's the appropriate use for us
and I've I've seen several people do
this they'll have a separate device for
their work uh content so I don't I don't
have that but we sort of do because we
have podcast Sean here yes and uh um you
as a work expense we we pay for his his
phone and so when we're on the road and
we want to do a live broadcast from
Facebook live or uh post some stuff from
Instagram live Jessica will also be with
us uh this this round of of tour stops
coming up so
we have people we can rely on it's like
having well not like it is having a
second device we're using someone else's
device and and me not having these
personal uh having these these items on
my personal phone is going to help me uh
and I'm going to be interested to look
at the tracking now that these are gone
from my phone yeah look at me too man I
can't wait I I I do love this app man
because like you said like as soon as I
realized something was tracking me like
I definitely picked it up less yeah and
and uh it's a it's so it's gamification
for the good and and that's also a good
thing like so you know like the fitbits
that people have or whatever the
actually you do this on your phone now
you can check your steps right yeah
that's gamifying it the and I freaking
hate that word but that's the the the
the word they've coined for the for the
good so instead of like acting on your
your habits to constantly twitch for the
next tweet or next like or whatever uh
it is okay I'm game ofun how little can
I check my phone or how many steps can I
take today on my health tracker those
are that's a positive way of using
gamification you know what's funny I uh
you know that I like to play some
Pokemon every once in a while okay Mari
and I be walking is that still a thing
well not for me anymore I'm not judging
it but I I did I thought it was like a a
limited time engagement oh no dude
they're doing the same thing like how
can we make them play more so uh Mar
I'll be walking around and it is fun
like I'll let her catch a Pokemon I'll
catch a PO whatever dude like it's
really ephemeral um it's just something
we'll do to goof around with each other
like while we're walking around that's
cute I think I mean you're doing it
together though I mean that's yeah which
is great but the problem is they started
doing the the how many days in a row
have you got on and caught a Pokemon
thing oh and it started making me like
feel like oh [__] I got to get up and at
least catch one so I can keep that
streak going and as soon as I had that
thought I'm like I'm getting rid of this
game I just deleted it yeah but yeah
it's it's nuts how they can make you
want to play it more anyway yeah you get
you get addicted so real quick on on the
addiction side of things we talked about
addiction is wanting without liking uh
but but really and our addictions even
these small ones like shopping is is
well could be a huge addiction the the
article will link to with the wired
article uh from from Adam alter he he
talked about a woman in there who was
$80,000 in credit card debt because she
she had had an ideal life but she had
this shopping addiction and and and hit
it from everyone but now there's the
World of Warcraft addiction the video
game uh addiction there's the smartphone
addiction and so I find that in my own
life and what I what I'll what I'll see
here by removing these apps from the
phone it doesn't mean I'm again not a
lite but I will probably bring them back
at some point the question is when when
is it appropriate and how can I use them
more appropriately I think you if you
swing the pendulum from one side to the
other eventually you figure out what is
the comfortable middle but it's usually
closer to the side you swung to where
you were trying to get away from yeah
absolutely be interesting to get because
now I got to go to my computer to check
Twitter uhhuh it'll we should get this
app for our computers as well is that
possible I think I think I think they do
have it we'll have to we'll have to
check on that but I think if not there
is an equivalent app for sure uh that
will that will show you the how much
time you're and by the way throughout
this whole this whole episode if you
have any tips and tricks and everything
else that that we're talking about if
you want to add to any of it we'll give
you phone number a little bit later you
can call in or send a voice memo to the
the email address and we'd love to hear
what apps you're going to recommend now
keep in mind I do think it's a bit
quixotic to to try to solve the
technological problems with
technology and and and you're it's it
just if you say it out loud it starts to
sound crazy like watching videos that
show you how to stop watching videos
like I'm going to build a robot that
kill the robots that are trying to kill
me right it it feels that way right yes
so Clive speaking of Technology a couple
other things before we move on to the
next question the last question we have
here but um uh I'm going to recommend
you go back and listen to our technology
podcast it's probably 95% different from
this episode it's all the way back at
episode number two at theminimalists.com
podcast but also there's an entire
chapter about technology in our book
it's called essential it's a essay
collection 150 essays about 12 different
topics of intentional living and there's
one entire chapter in there about
technology Sean if you could reach out
to him get him the the ebook version of
that or the audiobook version if we have
any more audible download codes it's
like a a six six and a half hour audio
book something crazy but there is a a um
a technology chapter I think you get the
most value from Clyde since you're
asking that question all right let's
move on our next question is from Kim in
Pennsylvania
my struggle is since I have jettisoned
my TV and begun to visit the internet
rather than live on it I sometimes feel
out of touch with current
events by that I mean real events not
what Kanye West is doing nice man but
you know my question is can you
recommend a minimalist news feed and by
minimalist I mean as much as possible
lean objective intelligent reporting of
national and international events in a
timely
fashion well first off Kim thanks for
your compliment uh we are definitely
listening and it's interesting because
social media is one way for us to listen
and especially was for the first I don't
know three four five years of of the
minimalists but once you reach a
particular critical mass it becomes a
full-time job trying to just respond to
people on email and social media that we
find the the best way we we've we've
slowed everything down quite a bit when
people want to contact us the the the
best way if you want to be 100% sure
we're going to see your your inquiry you
can send us a piece of mail so if you go
to our contact page it's the first thing
we recommend is you can you can mail us
a postcard and we get back to everyone
who who mails us something now we still
get a ton you we get a PO Box Sean's
always checking we get a PO box full of
mail but it's not nearly as is I mean
can you imagine if every tweet we got
someone had to mail it to us I me we'd
have we'd have to have the biggest PO
box at the post office right and and so
uh yes we are definitely listening in
fact I'm thinking back to our our very
first tour Ryan back in in 2011 it was
basically a listening tour we went out
and we did these these events with small
groups of people certainly fewer than 50
in in virtually every city right and and
we get out there and we listen listen to
what people were struggling with and
they would hear our struggles and this
this podcast has been a almost like
continuation of that in a way where it
allows us to listen in fact we're doing
that with our our upcoming events at the
Les is now tour we're doing the VIP
events beforehand so if you buy the
really good seats you pay a little bit
more for that but we um were're doing
the special event we didn't want it to
just be a meet and greet where we show
up and hug people like that's that's
fine but we we stay after and hug
everyone anyway so if you want to hug
you can always stay after they're
they're free and you don't have to pay
more for that but what we're going to do
is is have these little listening
sessions we'll have an intimate
discussion with the minimalists and and
hear about your struggles because we
found that face to face is the best way
to listen you can use these these tools
to augment that listening But ultimately
it it's it is about it is about cutting
down the barriers between us so so we
can listen better now to her question
Ryan I love what she said she said I now
visit the internet but I don't live on
it yeah it's funny when the question was
developing I thought she was going to
talk about how the internet time is just
become more now since she got rid of her
her TV cuz that's that's uh what
happened to me when um I was going out
with without TV for a while it was like
yeah but I can still go down there and
stream Netflix and veg out or you know
mhm it's very easy to do that no that's
great that she's been able to fill that
time I'm assuming with more useful
things than than watching TV but right
but getting rid of your your pacifier
and then not resorting to the internet
to to fill that
void that's really commendable we have
to find something better to fill the
void with right than some other pacifier
which it's very easy to do it's uh when
people quit smoking they often gain
weight cuz they move on to binge eating
right oh to see the Snickers bar every
time I want to
smoke I had a teacher who literally did
that oh my goodness in high school and
uh well he was telling us the story
about it okay but he was talking about
how he was you know 60 or 70 pounds
heavier than what he was and that's
because the attitude he adopted was oh
my good and then he was like well I just
moved to the funs side Snickers but then
like still it's not a healthy oh no
replacement yeah so so we do have to
figure out what to replace with I I went
without home internet for five years uh
so summer of 2011 till summer of 2016 uh
there was one small period in there when
we were living together Ryan where where
we had it shared but other than that I I
didn't have home internet just for a
very long time basically and it helped
me reprogram but you learn a lot about
loneliness right and so especially when
I got rid of my phone for a few months I
did another experiment where I got rid
of my my cell phone for two months so no
internet at home no TV no no cell phone
and like you really ReDiscover yourself
and and you ReDiscover books and you
ReDiscover loneliness and boredom and
and and being able to it's a great
experiment like if it wasn't for Mariah
having to go on online to do her coding
stuff uhhuh we'd get rid of it yeah I
mean and we went so long without it in
this apartment that we're in mhm and
Mariah just event she was just like
please like I need I need to do this
work online yeah it's you know it's it's
it's a good setting for her and she's
really good with it like for me like I
got like some I'll just turn the Wi-Fi
off on my laptop cuz I'm like yeah yeah
well I've had start to get sucked in so
I've had readers recommend this in the
past where they will have their
significant other not give them the W
change the Wi-Fi password and not give
it to them so they don't have access to
the W so if one person needs the other
one doesn't so that could be an
interesting experiment for you to try
out for a while um but anyway uh getting
on to her actual question she she say
she feels out of touch with current
events and and can we recommend a
minimalist
news feed now now if I were to take that
literally and say if you want like
stories about
minimalism your your best bet is to
follow two places uh follow us uh
because we Jessica curates really great
um news stories news yeah articles about
simplifying wardrobe and uh sometimes
the environment or waste or all these
different stories and they're not even
always opinions that we necessarily
agree with but they're great
perspectives right and and they're
interesting and they help us identify
and understand other people's stories so
yeah if you want to follow the
minimalists on social media you can do
that and and I think that's one place to
go the other one is if you want like
really great design and travel stuff
with respect to minimalism uh
specifically you can follow our side
project called minimalism life uh on
Twitter it's just minimalism so that
one's really easy to follow at
minimalism and it's minimalism life on
on Facebook and minimalism life on
Instagram as well and just well curated
beautiful stuff but I think what she's
actually asking is what how can I
simplify my my news stream basically and
not feel like I'm out of touch yeah I
mean I would suggest uh I mean Twitter
is it's to use it only for news would be
a good idea that's how I used to use it
before we became the minimalist it was
just my I would follow news and I would
follow the news I wanted to follow
because you can curate it but I also all
the artists and like bands and people
that I I was interested in what they
were doing that was the type of news for
me right so she mentioned she was not
interested in Kanye West so then she
would not follow Kanye West on Twitter
exactly but someone might be and that's
okay um but but yeah it's uh it's a
great way to curate a very minimal news
feed she asked for specific websites
like specific news sources MH you know I
mean every news has their own slant
right like every news Outlet even like
like the two that I visit the most are
are NPR and BBC like those are the ones
that if I'm like okay um did that law
pass or like there are some things that
I'm looking out for on the news every
once in a while like I'll go to one of
those those sites but even then
sometimes I feel like you know some of
their stories are are biased so I don't
think there's like a number one trusted
news source um but I I know I can
certainly get there and for the most
part get some like unbiased opinions
even though they'll still be sprinkled
in there every once in a while sure and
and if you're doing the if you're doing
the Twitter
thing liberally unfollow people if so if
if you if you see if you're following I
don't know the the where is she she's in
Harrisburg if if you're following the
Harrisburg times on Twitter I'm assuming
at your newspaper um and they start the
Harrisburg
Gazette that's the competitor oh
um anyway uh if you're following them
and they start posting a bunch of
stories about Kanye West unfollow them
it's okay and and then find something
else to follow right there'll be
recommendations and stuff and then you
want to keep it below the D dunbar's
rule so or dunar number
150 that because we can't it's hard for
our brain to to I mean I keep it way
below 100 I try to keep it below 50 if
possible following fewer than 50 places
now Josh let's not make this a contest
no I mean follow the least amount of
people well no because then you just
follow no one and and that that is and I
mean I could do that very easily I could
just go unfollow everyone I'd unfollow
you first Ryan thank
God but my point is that like if it's
overwhelming unfollow if it's too much
unfollow but if it if it just makes you
uncomfortable because you don't like the
perspective that could potentially be a
good thing so so I'm going to encourage
you Kim to to slow down your news a bit
so if you want to get off on if you want
to get offline alog together then uh you
can what I what I call slow news so I
subscribe to the New Yorker if you want
the other side of that you could also
subscribe to the National Review so you
sort of have a a left leaning magazine
Weekly Magazine and a right leaning
magazine and it slows it down now
granted there's still pernicious ads
that will be in that magazine so we have
to be aware of that when you see an
advertisement tell yourself this is just
an advertisement I was watching the 60
Minutes thing uh this this morning Ryan
while I Was preparing for this and there
was this uh drug advertisement like if
you have lowlevel arthritis like it
wasn't even like for bad arthritis you
can take this once daily pill and the
side effects I [__] you not man the side
effects one of them was cancer wow if
you have light arthritis when to get rid
of it here's a cancer pill good grief
and it always amazes me to like diarrhea
vomiting bloating but your acne will be
cured and and uh so I I think uh point
being is you'll still see advertisements
there just be aware that when when you
see advertisements say this is just an
advertisement and move on if you want
some newspapers New York Times versus
Wall Street Journal or maybe even LA
Times if you're out west you mean the
fake news Josh I don't even know what
that means yeah let me let me say you
know what actually I love that you don't
know what that means which it just goes
to show that you don't pay attention to
that much news Well I our news these
days is less fake than ever um if you go
back to the 1800s and look at the the
nonsense news from back then it was
virtually all fake like it's laughable
fake yeah yeah con man fake yes and and
and you snake oil salesman so uh New
York Times versus Wall Street Journal
it's a left versus uh a right side
opinion but I get most of my news
honestly when when things do creep into
to my Cranium it's from podcasts yeah
and and so I do listen I listen to a lot
of podcasts and I switch it up and again
that's another thing I unfollow and
unsubscribe liberally uh to to those
podcasts but and I there are ones I get
the most value from I know that I'll
probably never unsubscribe from but
there are a lot that I listen to that
have the both sides of the opinion so
I'll give you a couple of those real
quick if you want politics Bill Mah Real
Time with Bill Mah and Glenn Beck those
are the two I don't agree with either
one of them most of the time actually
but it allows me to land somewhere in
the middle yeah at least you can get
like an opinion on both sides yeah like
I
limbal is entertainment to me like it's
just funny to hear him go off on stuff
right but like that's how I look at it
as entertainment but it is uh and by the
way I don't listen to that religiously
I'm just thinking about like the times I
have listened to it but but it's like
yeah dude getting a dose of the far
right and then getting a dose of the far
left like you can at least uh yeah like
you said fall in the middle but what I
like about it too is it just helps me
get outside of that bubble that I feel
like sometimes I'm in politically mhm so
it's just nice to get the other side of
it yeah there's one other one I listened
to that is it's called Left Right and
center and it it provides all sort of
three sides you know the left the right
and the center and it's a weekly
politics podcast so if you're going to
listen to One podcast about politics
that's probably it gives you the most
balanced approach right there and a a
really short 30 minute burst and then um
is there anything else I listen to that
I mean I listen to a lot of podcasts
that that have nothing to do with news
but news tends to creep into them and so
I'll hear about I'll hear about all the
the big things yeah Colin right let's
know no thanks he does a really good job
of like incorporating current events
with with uh with his show yeah he does
a great job with it I I I agree he uh
and he ties it into whatever whatever he
wants to talk about that week which
which is great I mean it's called let's
know things because he wants to learn
things uh together with you well Kim we
were already in Pennsylvania by the time
this comes out so I can't give you any
tickets to the lesses now tour but but
we had such a blast it was so fun
um but I would love to give you a copy
of our book everything that remains it's
my favorite book uh of everything that
we've written it's my favorite thing
we've ever created actually it's a
memoir about the last five years of Our
Lives or the fiveyear transition really
from being these suit and tie corporate
guys to minimalists and how we
simplified our lives in the process so
Sean if you can reach out to her give
her the book or the audio book version
of that I would really appreciate it and
we'd love to hear what yall have to say
so if you have a a comment or a tip for
any of our callers today then leave us a
voicemail
7839 or you can also send a voice memo
to podcast at theminimalists.com we will
air our favorite comments and tips on
the next
episode dude we should come up with a
new email address for Sean and it should
be podcast Sean at the minimalist that's
I know that that the email address is
podcast at the minimalist but I like in
my brain I'm like
oh yeah we should just send it all to
podcast Sean at minimal. that is not an
email address it will not
work all right all right let's move on
to our hash askthe minimalists lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media Josh I just deleted all my
social media
though well I've got it on my my
computer thankfully we are on Twitter
and Instagram atthe minimalist and
facebook.com/ thee minimalist during the
lightning round this is where and I each
do our best to answer each question with
just a short sharable less than 140
character response we'll also put the
textt to these minimal maximums in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
py answers on social media if you'd like
our first question comes from Heather
I'd like to hear your strategy for
staying active and engaged on social
media while not becoming too dependent
on it or consumed by it all right my my
short answer to that one is to live
intentionally we must continually ask
ourselves is this useful and just to add
on to that real quick Ryan I I mean that
applies first to the stuff in our lives
but then it can it can bleed over to
every every other area of Life
relationships career passions whatever
is this useful for my life does it serve
a purpose does it bring me joy and if
not I I'm willing to let go as as we
just did yeah uh I answered her question
with a
question What would life be like if we
checked social media only once per day
that is good man with Facebook I check
it during the weekends it's two or three
times a day again because I'm monit
monitoring the page um and answering
people's questions and staying active
you know with that community that we
have and supporting that Community um
but during the week man like I will
check in on average once a day but like
I did not check it
yesterday um which like probably I've
got 100 notifications sitting in there
now um but uh but yeah it's it's uh it's
it's it's it's something that has really
really helped me avoid that anxiety
feeling of seeing that notification oh
my God I got to get that notification
off my screen it's just like I'll just
check it I don't have like a certain
time I do it at night it's more like
okay uh I'm sitting here twiddling my
thumbs yeah instead of going
to cnn.com it's like all right I'm going
to go and knock this Facebook stuff out
but some days I forget to check it yeah
but uh but yeah I would I would
encourage people out there to to yeah if
it's not once a day if that's like too
crazy then make it twice a day but but
uh but be intentional with it Sarah
writes why do you use social media as a
minimalist hypocrite no she didn't say
that I just do that in there how do you
recommend using it intentionally well
I'll answer the first part uh to that my
my short answer is just three words
minimalists aren't
Lites yeah I wrote a tools are as useful
as the user that's good Emily rode in
how can I use media more mindfully when
a lot of my interests photography
writing and reading involve interacting
online all right well my short answer to
that one is let go of distractions make
room for intention yeah I think I uh
touched on this earlier today this is
much more piy than what I was saying uh
earlier in our conversation but I just
said The more we practice selfcontrol
the better we get at it so Emily I don't
care where you start maybe it is
starting with that once a day checking
uh uh social media mentality or maybe
it's twice a day but put something some
kind of limit on on yourself to start
practicing that self-control and as the
as time goes on and the more
self-control we practice the easier
easier it gets it's like anything else
in life practice makes perfect our last
question is from Miguel what is
essential that we must watch consume and
participate in all right well my answer
to that one is essential is
perspectival you don't have like a list
of shows that he should veg out on I've
really been enjoying the young Pope
recently oh dude I've only seen the
first episode of that I need I need to
check that I forgot all about that
um it's just funny though I was just
thinking I wish there was a list of like
all the things all the movies you should
watch uhuh all the shows you should the
best shows you should watch but
everything is so uh well like you said
perspect iable uhuh um there isn't just
one magic list like the list for me is
going to be different uh than the list
for you and so forth and so on so uh I
had fun with this question I said watch
yourself consume less
participate in your local
community yeah I think I think that's
that's beautiful man so what must you
watch consume and participate in watch
yourself consume less participate in
your local community man that's great
it's a great way to end it all right
well let's uh let's move on let's move
on to added value this is the portion of
the show where Ryan and I um we talk
about something that's added value to
our lives recently we're going to do
something a little bit different today
Ryan I'm going to recommend two things
that I've already recommended I'm going
to recommend them again because I'm
getting value from them still awesome so
uh it's the best album of the year so
far is Drake's album by far it's there's
it's a good album yeah everything else
has fallen to second and third fourth I
mean there's some other great albums I
recommended this year elbows uh album is
great um aquilo's album is
outstanding um what was the the americ
American teen album we recommended yeah
KH khed yeah uh that one is outstanding
but Drake's album I just keep going back
and listening to it so it's growing on
me even more it is it is funny how like
it is one of the every single album that
he has put out even like that Take Care
album which I love man yeah it I had to
listen to it like two or three times to
like really appreciate it yeah it's
really weird it's funny how albums are
like that radio heads uh album when it
came out last year was the same thing
for me where it was like man this isn't
really that good and then at least do it
a couple a couple times and I'm like
this album is
amazing and the second thing I'll
recommend is uh beex and I just watched
this together first time I watched it I
watched it by myself which I don't
usually do but uh Gerard carmichel has
that special called 8 it's on HBO and we
we sat down we made the time to to watch
this together and it was better the
second time even though it's a I'll say
comedy special to me it's an honesty
special he he uses jokes to to really is
it just one is it just like a one and a
half hour special or like an hour long
probably it's sound like a series no
it's just it's it's just him in front of
a crowd and and it's part of it
certainly comedy but it's just like
overt honesty and at first parts of it
will turn you off and you're like wait
he's just being I mean he's being
exaggerating honest in some cases but it
it was just really good so Gerard
carmichel he he's definitely my top
three comedians uh if he's not number
one he's up there with christalia and
Anthony jessick I mean it's it's such a
good special man and Beck's just
watching her crack up like the whole
hour man like there's like actually not
the whole hour you don't even watch the
TV you just like to watch be Beck crack
up yeah I she's so beautiful man like I
just watch it and I'm like oh it's
anyway well what's been adding value to
your life recently right you know what's
so funny man is like I feel the same way
about
but for some reason I hate making that
public like I hate making our
relationship cuz I feel like that's the
one thing I have that people can't dive
deep into yeah yeah and that's so funny
man it's uh I think you and I are like
you're becoming more extroverted I mean
beex was telling us the other day how
you were um you guys were watching a
special maybe it was the Gerard what is
his name Gerard carmichel uh Gerard ger
carmichel ger carmichel and you were
like maybe it was special but you were
like we should have people over and
watch this special yeah yeah yeah and
she's like really I'm like actually
no but here that's how good it was I was
like we should we should invite like
Ryan and Sean and maybe Nate over and
like we we'll uh and I'm like that's a
lot of work man I'm just going to tell
them to watch
this uh my recommendation dude I went to
this game night um not last Friday but
the Friday before anyway it it was uh
the DJ who interviewed us here locally
oh yeah remember he invited me over for
a game night yeah he had this game
called uh Captain sonar so it requires
eight people to play you can't play with
less or more it just requires eight
people to play two teams of four and it
is like Battleship on steroids like it
is it is so much fun so uh I'm just
recommending a game for those board game
lovers out there yeah um who like to
have like big game nights like this is
an eight person board game and it is so
much fun um man if I if I try to explain
exactly how it works I'm going to not
really do it justice I'm going to do a
bad job of of paraphrasing the rules you
have to have eight people have to have
eight people but yeah it's uh it is the
best way the best way to describe it is
Battleship on steroids so if you like
Battleship uhhuh and you like
steroids now like what kind of steroids
is it like trt or are we talking all
right never mind no it's it's a great
game I will I highly recommend it all
right let's move on to right here right
now this is where we get to talk about
what's going on in the lives of the
minimalist this episode's running long
so I'll be really quick here I already
mentioned we're going on tour it's the
less is now tour we're going to give a
talk about minimalism we record a live
version of this podcast and we'll dish
out a bunch bunch of free hugs 47 cities
over at lisn now.com yes we are coming
to a if you in North America we are
coming to a city near you uh it's within
a very short distance if we're not
coming to your city it's the next city
over so there's a bunch of them there
lesis now.com also our documentary
minimalism is finally available
worldwide it's on Netflix everywhere
where there is Netflix and if you don't
have Netflix don't worry it's available
worldwide on Vimeo and a lot of other
platforms as well just go to minimalism
film.com speaking of video or film we
have two web series that are out there
right now one is called simples it's an
animated web series it's four different
episodes you can see all four episodes
now they're short episodes anywhere from
I think 2 minutes to six or seven
minutes long and they're they're little
bite siiz bits of intentionality you can
share with other people uh that's out
there right now it's on our YouTube page
it's
youtube.com/ thee minimalist and also
while you're there you you can see the
making minimalism web series so if you
like their documentary want to see how
we made it how we went from just an idea
and and Zer dollars to having on Netflix
and and millions if not tens of millions
of people have have seen it at this
point and it's been a really huge
success you can see all the behind the
scenes stuff our very talented director
mat the Aela has put that together and
we it's really about how Matt made the
movie I mean when every time I say yeah
we made this movie like in my head I'm
like throwing quotes around
[Laughter]
we
we made this movie it's really good I'm
I'm really happy with the way the making
minimalism has turned out it's it's uh I
think it's good if you just want to like
you said see behind the scenes but also
some of the episodes get a little
technical right uh for you know aspiring
filmmakers out there documentary
aspiring documentarians out there it's
nothing that's going to be over your
head though it's not exact exactly like
it's it's beautifully done like it's
entertaining and then it also you you
can actually learn something from it too
exactly yeah that's great all right
that's all I got advertisements suck but
if you want to support this show you can
over at theminimalists.com
donate you can donate one time or or
monthly if you want to help us out that
way we keep this 100% advertisement free
and also if you do find Value in what we
do we'd really appreciate a review on
iTunes or wherever you listen to podcast
Ryan you got anything else all I have
left are some voicemail comments and
tips from our
listeners hi my name is yarden and I'm
calling from Brooklyn New York I um had
an idea uh regarding minimizing baby
stuff um in regards to a question that
appeared on the parenting episode um I
find it incredibly hard still to get rid
of anything that has my baby's name on
it uh he's almost one year old uh but I
do find that with time and as he becomes
more ingrained in our lives it gets
easier and I don't feel that I need to
hold on to every single thing so my idea
is that um
in in in line with um the minimalist
attitude in general to revisit things um
every few months I kind of take a look
at the things that I've kept around um
cards that we got when he was born
little gifts that we never use stuff
like that and every few months I find
that I can get rid of a couple more
things that don't actually add that much
value or Mean That Much Anymore um so
you know it's kind of an ongoing process
it's not a One-Stop shop but it
works hey uh calling from Minneapolis so
you guys don't really have a spot for
this type of thing on your show but your
last episode about Jobs made me think
that it'd be fun to call with an update
um so my name is Jess but you would
remember me as Intergalactic death with
the exclamation point um so back in your
careers episode forever ago you read my
iTunes comment um I was 24 God offered
an impressive sounding job and turned it
down because I wanted to pursue more of
a meaningful life um more valuable life
for myself and um a lot of it was
because of the values that I found from
you know discovering minimalism and
specifically like your guys blog and the
podcast really helped me find those
values I could recognize when something
wasn't aligning with them um and I'm 25
now full-time personal trainer and yoga
instructor and I'm making actually
really good money working in a career
which aligns with my values and I am
really passionate about health and
fitness and the work that I do it really
helps my clients to improve themselves
and it's really rewarding and it's
contributing a lot so I'm really happy
um and another cool thing is like I can
use minimalism a lot when I'm helping
these people and helping them get
focused on what's important to them and
living you know just better in general
and once I've paid off my student loans
my boyfriend and I are going to save a
bunch of a up a bunch of money and hit
the road we're going to go rock climb
around the country because that's the
main passion that I have in life and I
want to give it my all for a while and
then who knows but um thanks again like
you've had a big impact on my life and
really positive knowing you guys and
your work and um thanks again for
killing it and I look forward to seeing
whatever you guys decide to
do hey this is TJ first of all I just
wanted to say Josh and Ryan thank you so
much for putting together all of the
work that you do um I was introduced to
you guys at on Netflix in the middle of
December as soon as it came out and
completely blew my mind um I really
connected with the story that you guys
told and I'm a child of the 80s was born
in June of 81 uh in Cincinnati Ohio um
my parents uh moved further east and
that and got divorced and there was
plenty of issues there that sounded very
similar to your issues uh in your story
and um I kind of grew up thinking that I
could make a ton of money and be very
happy and pursued a career on the west
coast for about eight or nine years and
made a boatload of money or at least I
thought I did and spent a boatload of
money and um when I saw your documentary
it really resonated with me and for the
last two months it's made uh just such a
significant difference in my life so I I
can't thank you guys enough for doing
what you do um I I really have told a
lot of people in my family as well that
you know this this could be the answer
to why we're all so stressed because it
it seems like I've been asking a
question for a long time about why are
all of the successful people that I know
so unhappy it seems like the the more
successful you are the bigger your
business is or the more money you're
making ultimately you really just aren't
very happy so when I saw what you guys
were doing it seemed like such a good
answer to that question so again thank
you very much all right y'all that's it
for this episode if you have a question
for the minimalists give us a call 40621
97839 you can also email a voice memo to
podcastthe
[Music]
minimalist.org you think that you need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you be
fine without
it every little thing that you got to
have every little thing that you got to
have you got to reach for
and you got a grab oh I bet that you be
fine without
it so take your eyes
we or take your
[Music]
eyes